it's not just an attack on our privacy
it's also an attack on democracy
we all have this like literally in our
pockets there are cameras on front and
on the back there's a microphone so I
think everybody realizes if someone
creeps into there that they're really
taking over your life
[Music]
Pegasus is a brand of spyware and it
completely takes over your phone so it
has access to your messages to your it
can activate your camera your microphone
it has access to your images to your
documents to your apps everything there
are also other brands of spyware
it's not just an attack on our our
privacy it's also an attack on on
Democracy because we need journalists
who can investigate and and expose you
know crime and wrongdoing we need
opposition politicians we need critical
ngos we need lawyers we need people who
can freely
um you know scrutinize power hold the
power to account control it's Democratic
control
they can be black males they can be
discredited
they can be harassed there's a chilling
effect people are are you know they're
not outspoken anymore they're a bit
worried about whom they meet what kind
of information they store on their
devices
[Music]
the abuse of spyware is definitely a
threat to the Integrity of Elections and
it's not just about politicians because
how can elections be fair if journalists
are unable to to scrutinize government
and to report on you know what the
government has done well and what it has
done wrong
[Music]
the role of parliamentary Watchdog is
one of the very important tasks of the
European Parliament there's a handful of
governments abusing spyware and here I
think we have to conclude that in many
cases European laws have been violated
and the European commission has malt
acted so this is something where I think
the European Parliament really has to
put pressure on the European commission
it should do its job
[Music]